it's pitching tonight his 20th start he
has a record of seven wins four losses
right-hander jose barrios and that
brings ohtani to the plate and we'll see
what a day of rest does to the swing
it's been well documented that post
all-star break it's been a struggle
four for 28 14 strikeouts
ohtani
right center in the gap and it goes to
the wall
big man can run celestino up with it and
that's a nice swing
and a double
02.
fastball smack to short gonna try to get
the runner there
and then the ball is thrown away
what a disaster and that's two bases and
ohtani's going to score
simmons thought he could get otani who
was away from second he didn't get him
polanco then turned it like a double
play and threw it into the dugout that
was as disjointed as it gets ceno almost
looked like he didn't see the ball
cenote gave up on it as well
and iglesias really hits breaking balls
exceptionally well 339 batting average
that's the best in baseball on breaking
balls
on that breaking ball smokes it and i
believe it's fair into the corner it is
that's going to score upton
and
slides in with a double that disappeared
from our view right this time he opens
up the hips brings the hand in and hooks
it right down the line
keeps it fair
and those numbers now 40 hits versus
breaking balls
and patrick sandoval is trying to follow
up what's been two pretty nice starts in
his normal routine of stressing those
hips because he's the guy that used that
lower half to drive towards the plate
looking for a solid effort for patrick
sandoval today fastballs 91-97
very good change-up slider and curveball
back-to-back starts for patrick sandoval
popped up
stassi is there
and that's an easy out
patrick sandoval the 24 year old
oh beautiful change up 86 swinging a
miss
and two quick outs here in the first
breaking ball it sounded like he busted
his bat and fletcher out in shallow
right is going to make the catch
and patrick sandoval goes one two three
through the twins in the first
there he is
tom hallian ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the show
curveball
tom hallian show it's how it's done
i'm on the il after that one
and halian was one of those
pulled on the ground
iglesias to first so here's polanco
popped out to stassi the catcher and he
checks his swing and hits one fair on
the first base side it's rolling near
the bag just a nine pitch inning for
patrick sandoval pitch is throwing off
the timing of a hitter
again again
rooker goes down
two-two here
dalton hits it hard uh-oh mayfield again
fletcher's turn
don't hit it to mayfield josh donaldson
three times yesterday
and this a garden-variety 5-4-3
double play
until the bottom of the eight
oh fastball 95.
when you're thinking change up 95 must
look like 105. four seen fastball
and a lot of times when you have a
catcher reach it back like that usually
you don't get these type of results but
because he's looking off speed
got the express instead
there it is
yeah you tell him tom hallian inside
corner
all over it
the old back up breaking ball
next pitch will be number 65 for
sandoval and it's a swing and a miss and
he got him on a changeup right there and
sandoval strikes out the side
so he has seven strikeouts in this game
smash great stop simmons throws him out
what a play by andrewton simmons
not supposed to do that to a former
teammate are you
no he's not getting any hits he's not
giving up any hits it's a great play by
simmons
you understood he needed to get to his
feet in a hurry and make a good throw to
first base
high fly left center field
larnick going back
and making the catch on the track who
away
[Applause]
it blew up in his face
larnick
with the line drive catch another one
two three inning for rios
really good they're not these guys won't
be good they are
so patrick sandoval isn't good he is
great tonight
strikes out polanco eight punchouts
tight
late breaking with slider my blanco has
been swinging the bat very very well
coming into this game change up his
bread and butter
got him
nine strikeouts
six innings
no hits
patrick sandoval is on it tonight in
minnesota
[Music]
and polanco made a nice play
got him
and barrios
creates one of the tom hallian all third
strikes 15 in a row set down by barrios
you can see jeffers set up in
watched barrios just
drive this ball into his glove didn't
have to move it much
patrick sandoval tonight has thrown 79
pitches
nine strikeouts
walked a man
hit a man
and so far he has no hit the minnesota
twins be careful first pitch against
donaldson here if you're patrick
sandoval
breaking ball in the air and playable
for upton
two down here in the seventh
3-2 pitch
got him
10 punch-outs and still
in minnesota tonight the twins
are being no hit
[Music]
twins catcher
got him change up and i'll tell you why
rich that was a great time to walk
behind the mount because he's in a great
rhythm
got him that's a dozen punch outs he did
it again
four outs away patrick sandoval taking a
no-hitter to the bottom of the ninth
against the minnesota twins
now rooker
lines it
oh
it's fair and the no hitter ends
with one out in the ninth
and rooker is safe at second
joe madden
wants the baseball iglesias is ready you
got a veteran in donaldson who is the
tying run
at the plate and patrick sandoval so
close
two outs away from the no hitter
will leave with a two nothing lead
in the bottom of the ninth and donaldson
at the plate and the ball ripped into
the left field corner
and the twins will get a run
donaldson digging for second here's the
throw and he's in there
an rbi double on the first pitch
the first relief pitcher
gordon the tying run
3-2 to snow
got him stacy holds it
[Applause]
patrick sandoval didn't get
the no-hitter
but he gets the win
after
eight
and
two-thirds brilliant innings
and the angels a much needed win
iglesias closes it
13 strikeouts just one hit allowed by
sandoval
so close to history